[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that uh
that should be working out oh dang it I
was gonna hold on one second I'll be
right back
ah
I do this a lot I tend to think of like
oh that's that's a thing I should do and
then I forget to do the thing that's
I feel like that might actually be a
rough summation of my life
uh
you like the pants thank you Diana I uh
I picked them up in Provincetown when I
went there with Liz
they felt appropriately gay they're very
gay pants from a very gay town
uh if you ever have the chance to go to
Provincetown I encourage you to do so
so yeah uh anyone who caught
the first couple minutes yeah
um Pyro
uh pyro moved on
uh earlier today
so if I'm a little bit on the bummed
outside that's not the only thing that's
like gone wonky this month unfortunately
but it's been a big thing
but uh yeah if I seem a little uh a
little drained a little low energy that
is a um
that's a sizable contributing factor
but uh I hope everybody is uh is doing
all right
um hey folks hey Carolyn Diana oh hi
Molly haven't seen you in a while miss
Wicked Wolf Aaron Brandon I'm not gonna
catch everybody but like I want to
uh uh so yeah
uh I got oh crap I got a as soon as this
is done I need to upload my review for
um third episode of House of the Dragon
uh that'll go up in the break room
I don't know about 20 minutes half an
hour after this uh
uh after this happens
uh John thank you very much for the
Super Chat is pyro pet of yours sort of
uh pyro was my kiddos rat well one of
them
um and but you know he he lived at my
house here the rats didn't go back and
forth
um so but yeah so kind of
um
and I I uh I suppose it's worth
uh reminding Folks at this point that
um
while I try and keep up with the chat
the super chats is the only thing that
will guarantee that I will see and
respond to your channel you'll also get
a heart of appreciation from me uh at
about quarter to eight I will pop over
to the con the Council of Geeks Discord
and address questions uh from the
patrons over there
um and other than that we're just we're
just here to here to ramble
um Ben couldn't stay but sends his level
oh no that was nice of him I appreciate
that uh hope is okay boba's doing fine
boba boba is is frisky and Lively and
and he's he's in good shape it's so he
uh he's gonna be he's gonna be getting
some extra attention because I don't
want him to be lonely and generally
it's tough with rats because they are
they're social animals
um and it's generally nice to get them
you know as a pair uh or you know just
get several of them but the the tricky
thing is when one of them goes
um you know that can leave the other
ones lonely but it's not always a great
idea
um to bring in like a new rat especially
if it's like a younger rat that may not
go great so you know it gets uh it gets
tricky
hey
like your earrings thank you thank you I
I need to wear these more than I do
um I was the kid taking it I mean you
know uh about as well as kids do
you know it's not it's not the first pet
she's ever lost it's not her first rodeo
but she
she loves her pets very very very much
so you know she's sad because
yeah
because we all are at the moment
anyway uh big news I
finally had the gender talk with my mom
and it went great oh that's wonderful
Molly she fully accepts me and even gave
me clothes and offered to teach me
makeup with that oh
oh that
makes me so happy when I hear that oh my
goodness
uh
oh Diana Bell thank you very much for
the Super Show I never know what to ask
in the Discord or the chat so just have
a Fiverr anyways that is yes that is
greatly appreciated I mean I have my
house taxes due in a couple of months
and that
that always hurts ah
so taxes are always a big pain in my ass
because there's the house taxes then you
know there's end of the year taxes and
I've got the house taxes every six
months because it it's more workable
that way for me rather than doing them
annually because then it's it's just
it's too big of a lump sum and it like
just with ADHD and trying to get money
set aside it's it's troublesome
I lost my first pet around the same time
I watched a fairly odd parents about
Timmy's pets that was a mistake
I'll take your word for it I never
really watch that show very much uh
other than the theme song which I
thought was uh was was a good one but
I'll I'll take your word on that
um to get you up to date on my Buffy and
Angel watch through even though it was
all because of a silly magic spell it
did warm my heart that Buffy asked Giles
to give her away like I love Giles is uh
Giles probably my favorite character
what's househack well technically Paul
it's property taxes
um
and it's just it's it's something that's
due on the house so
it's a thing
where I finished streams of fire enjoyed
the whole thing I really like the world
you built and it was a really good
adventure story thank you cappuccino
crafts I appreciate that
um if you have a Goodreads account if
you wouldn't mind writing a review
that'd be awesome but but I I like I'm
I'm very glad that you enjoyed it
the CGI and the Pinocchio remake looks
atrocious uh shouldn't they should have
had the actor in makeup and concept well
I mean they shouldn't have made the
movie
that's what that's what they should have
done they should have just not made it I
I it's not that the CGI is bad it's that
they're making the strange choice to
make the CGI look just about identical
to
how a lot of the actual animated
characters looked
which is a weird damn choice
to me and again it's just one more thing
that undermines why do these things
exist
uh what do you think of the internet
archives after watching your video on
HBO Max I found some of their content uh
preserved on their internet archives
um in general like as a practice are
um important and helpful Unfortunately
they are subject to the same
um copyright and takedown notices as
anybody else so
you know stuff can get hosted on
archives but if the originator of the
content says hey
scrub it they kind of have to
so like
they're a good thing to have but they're
not protected in any ways so
you know I really love Giles in the
first five seasons I consider Canon not
really after that I like Giles past that
like Giles returning in season six
at the end and just knocking back Willow
I think is one of the great re-entrances
in television because he's been gone for
most of the season and you know Willow's
gone dark whatever you think of that
storyline but she's she's the she's the
villain at the end spoilers for like a
20 year old season of television at this
point but you know she's like uh no
force on Earth can stop me she just gets
blasted back and in steps trials I'd
like to test that theory oh
I love it
freaking love it
it didn't clarify this last week uh did
you notice amity's new hairstyle
uh or did you just notice the color
change I think I did notice uh the
hairstyle change
I mean the color brings more attention
to it I think I remember noticing it
I don't know you're asking me to think
back and remember when or if I noticed
something and like my brain's not built
for that kind of recall
kind of falling off the Marvel bandwagon
mainly because recently they've shown
they're more whoa okay never mind that
message just went away I was in the
middle of reading it uh uh oh well
Joseph Gordon-Levitt lacks the charm
that Cliff Edwards had as Jiminy Cricket
well I mean that's a matter of opinion
but again I don't I don't I don't know
why it's a thing that's going to exist I
don't understand
do you want to see more guest stars in
each episode of She-Hulk or do you think
it would be too gimmicky if we got a
Wong like Cameo each time I mean given
that it's effectively a sitcom I I think
this is a show that is has a lot more
leeway to lean into gimmickry than a lot
of the Marvel shows do I don't have a
strong opinion one way or the other I
don't think if we saw a drop off in
guest stars that I would demand more nor
do I think if we kept seeing them that
I'd be going these shouldn't be here I'm
just like I think it'll work either way
personally
uh happy belated belated Labor Day yes
happy labor day uh and no I did not take
the day off really in a meaningful way
uh so
things like Labor Day lose a lot of
meaning when you are self-employed
uh that was a really great video of your
digital rights ownership is not really
protected great to raise awareness yeah
best as I can because like it's
it's a mess it's real bad out there
Buffy Merlin Doctor Who Anthony Stewart
had has completed the sci-fi fantasy
Trifecta I mean like he's just good he's
just good and stuff it's great
uh he's just he always seems to have a
nice presence and I've heard like
numerous like really sweet stories about
him like offset so that's that's always
nice hopefully nothing nasty ever comes
out about him I'd be real I think I
think that one would hurt even more than
Josh Whedon did
um you can only choose one of these
characters one of these character arcs
Willow or Wesley oh Wesley Wesley's got
one of the best character arcs
um in The Buffy verse definitely if not
in television it's a great Arc because
when you see how he starts
versus how he ends
if you just see those two things you'd
be like how is that the same guy but the
process of watching him is really well
done and really well paced out
um I love Willow but I loved Willow at
the beginning
um so she was good even before her Arc
happened Wesley is irritating at the
beginning so if he didn't have his ark
then I'd never have liked him so I think
that's an easy call for me to make
question have you played the recent
Guardians of the Galaxy game because the
general consensus is they blow both
movies out of the water I I have not and
I won't because it's fully rendered 3D
Graphics which means it will make me
motion sick so no no plans to play that
uh you should specify we're talking
about uh Willow Rosenberg going dark not
Willow Park going dark I don't even know
who Willow Park is
so
um
I don't know if that's I don't I don't
know what you're referencing
uh I also have a lot of work to do but
I'm here so that I can have a breather
well I'm glad you took the Breather here
with us
he was good in Rocky Horror Show too
I've seen like little clips of Anthony
Stewart had uh in Rocky Horror and yeah
he uh he looked like he was real good
for the part
uh what's the copy of She-Hulk behind
you oh this is
um
this is 1989 Sensational She-Hulk this
is actually
um it's all in one bag but this is the
this is the first six issues this was
reviewed um on
uh tough like a girl podcast that I do
with my partner Liz over on the fire and
water Network we reviewed this uh last
month uh we got we only did the first
five issues but that's that's what that
is I haven't I haven't navigated it back
to the long box yet which I should
kind of fallen off the Marvel bandwagon
mainly because recently they've shown
their more quantity over quality to me
you know if you like the recent Marvel
stuff more power to you I
I don't know if I necessarily agree in
terms of the movies but I I would say
that it does not feel like as much care
is going into the shows as I would like
um
so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna hard
disagree I'm just gonna say I'm not
quite there uh in the same way happy
anniversary to this channel thank you
Miss Wicked Wolf the um the live stream
we do in two weeks is gonna be more
dedicated
um you know sort of anniversary party
and I'll have something uh you know I'll
have more
um
uh spicy water than I'm currently
drinking
just you know with a pet dying uh
I I was given the very solid advice up
maybe maybe don't drink tonight
uh
Willow from the our house you know her
oh
I forgot her last name I don't know a
lot of those characters last names I
know Amity blight I know loose neceda
uh
eat a claw Thorn I don't know Gus's last
name I don't know Willow's last name
rain Whispers I remember
yeah there's a bunch of characters whose
last names I don't remember so there we
go
what does the animated Cannon should be
live action remade
none of them
none of none of them Black Cauldron I
wouldn't get too uppity about I still
wouldn't care but like it wouldn't upset
me because the movie didn't really work
so like it's one thing to try and take
another crack at a story that did not
work
that makes more sense to me than trying
to recreate a classic anything that's a
classic
I don't like I
years and years and years and years ago
before I was even I was gender fluid on
the channel I had a whole lengthy
rant
about just no just stop
with these damn things have we seen
rings of power yet yes Freddy I have a
review up in the break room of Geeks
it's my secondary Channel where a lot of
the review content goes
uh will you get back uh in the bath for
the anniversary I
considered that
I mean maybe I could
uh I I have
I have not uh I have not done a live
stream from the bath in quite a while we
could bring that back
oh maybe maybe we'll see
uh
so going back to the Guardians of the
Galaxy game since you're not going to
play it do you care about spoilers I
don't personally care about spoilers but
other people in the chat might so might
not be the forum for that
uh I'll have something I'm keep meaning
to watch but requires either an
additional subscription or piracy
huh yeah that's tough oh well
a pirate's life for me
I mean I think there is an opportunity
to remake a movie in live action 101
Dalmatians was pretty good see I didn't
even like that
even back in um
in the 90s when that happened I remember
thinking why
uh
a lot of people give that a pass because
it's not from the same batch of them but
no I think that's a bad I think that was
a bad idea too
I had a sequel which was worse
uh
sorry about your loss thank you bye
cover I appreciate that love the
earrings thank you I should wear these
more than I do I think part of the
reason I don't wear them that much is I
kind of need to have my hair up because
if my hair is down you won't see one of
them and so depending on which ear I do
on which you'd only see the sheet or
you'd only see the day but you wouldn't
see the other one because my hair would
be covering it so I think I think that
might be one of the reasons I don't I
don't wear them more
live remake of Brother Bear but
featuring indigenous actor director
would be interesting
complete from the ground up rework with
like an indigenous producer an
indigenous writer and an indigenous
director
maybe but if they're just gonna stick an
indigenous director and Indigenous
actors onto a prefab script that's
basically the same damn thing as before
I'm sorry I still don't think that's
creatively worth doing
I just I don't
uh Glenn Close was awesome in that movie
oh she put her heart and soul into it
still wasn't a good movie did not need
to exist
Vera would never support piracy I that's
no absolutely I would never support
privacy I was just singing a song you
know you know songs
a pirate's life is a Wonderful Life
you know these are just fun songs
uh
probably must have been fun for the cast
to work with real life dogs notoriously
that is usually not the case
I mean it's it's the old
um WC Fields saying never work with
children or animals
recently rewatched the Poirot episode
appointment with death which stars Tim
Curry and Mark gaydus's Father and Son
oh
that's interesting pairing that could
work I could see that I could see that
did you know that in the early 2010s
there was a ton of Marvel cartoons uh
that I think were okay not great but
okay my favorite uh
uh would have to be Hulk and the Agents
of Smash I did know they existed I
didn't watch any of them but I did know
they existed I had um
at a uh niece and nephew
um who
uh watched that stuff sometimes so I
caught like little bits of it being over
at their house
have I ever considered a beehive hairdo
well no because I I don't know how to
style
like I I do not know how to style hair
at all so short answer no I seldom
figure out how to do a French braid on
myself and that's not even that
difficult
Disney's Atlantis and Treasure Planet
are deeply underrated films agree on
Treasure Planet
half agree on Atlantis Atlantis is
visually a magnificent film
didn't really do much for me
plot and honestly a lot of the
characters
so I I appreciate that some people
really love it
um I love its look
kinda it I do love Treasure Planet
though but that's also important because
like I'm just a sucker for Treasure
Island The Narrative so like most
adaptations of Treasure Island I like
just because I like the core story
uh personal Disney uh
uh would personally Disney would better
make haste of pirate six with depth
opening that jar with dirt ah yeah no
the Pirates franchise I mean I think
they're they're shooting their best shot
getting Margot Robbie and and uh
sort of trying to move forward without
depth because whatever you think of the
court cases or whatever else even before
all that those things were performing
less and less and less well with him at
the front they just were
another remake that didn't need to exist
Tim Burns Alice in Wonderland announced
through the Looking Glass so
the thing is I do not consider like I
agree with you they didn't need to exist
I would push back on the idea that they
were remakes though they were
um especially that first one was more of
a re-adaptation of the source material
it wasn't really approached like it was
a remake
um of the previous Disney film it wasn't
treated that way at all
um how do you have a niece and nephew
when you are an only child
um so I was wondering if anyone was
going to ask that uh more accurate would
have been to say
um
former niece and nephew in law
so these would be my kiddos mother's
niece and nephew
um
it was just easier to say niece and
nephew rather than go through the whole
thing
uh I keep trying to get a YouTuber's
attention not you but she doesn't seem
to respond to my comments as of late uh
how do I know whether I've become a
Karen it's hard to know Black cover
because not different YouTubers handle
their comments sections differently some
just flat out do not handle their
comments at all depending on the size of
the YouTuber that that might actually
get passed off uh to somebody else like
if they have any kind of team supporting
them that's probably somebody else's job
to handle the comments uh there are
YouTubers I know only look at the
comments for like the first three or
four hours of video is up
um when it's most likely being viewed by
their subscribers before it gets latched
onto maybe people who are going to leave
not nice stuff and then they don't look
at comments after that so you know it's
not knowing how this YouTuber approaches
their comments it's hard to say whether
or not you actually have a shot at them
seeing your
um seeing your comment at all uh and or
what the best way to get notice would be
so uh not everyone approaches them the
same way I manage my own comments and I
do it diligently which is not always fun
so I get why a lot of others don't do I
follow toucan birdie no I still haven't
even seen Bojack
Don Novella improvised nearly all his
lines as Vinnie and Atlantis
Vinnie which one was Vinnie oh he was
the explosives guy wasn't he I did like
him
I yeah I liked him he was one of the
ones I liked
Maleficent didn't need to exist I would
say of the ones that were
in some ways direct takes even if not
direct
uh remakes
I would say Maleficent had the most
artistic justification for existing
um it didn't quite deliver
on that but I think its premise had the
most promise
I'm talking about during live streams oh
well I mean best guess then is usually
to make use of super chats um again
depending on the size of the
um YouTuber a lot of them
um
a lot of them will you know kind of
either do what I do where they try and
keep up but they might miss stuff or
there are some that explicitly won't
address your stuff unless it's a super
chat so like it's it's hard to know
have I ever seen Christopher Robin with
Ewan McGregor I have not uh it seemed
depressing actually
uh imagine if she run the Princess of
Power had ended with the door getting
together with glamor and Catra going off
into the Wilderness because she feels
she isn't ready for true love
I see minus Theodore getting together
with glimmer that's actually kind of how
I thought they should end it before I
saw season five and I do think they
actually did pull off season five but
initially my thought was
um Catra can't recover the damage she's
done to Adora and adora's friends and
that includes Scorpio so in my mind I
figured the best shot for her was to
leave with
um
uh Lonnie Kyle and Rogelio because they
were people who she had a connection
with but while she hadn't always been
nice to them she hadn't broken the those
relationships as much so she could still
lean on them for support without
um you know without having causes much
damage and maybe build something better
um that would that would have been my
call uh before seeing season five
and again I think what they did was
better so there you go the voice cast
for Hulk and Agents of Smash are Clancy
Brown as red Hulk that works Elijah just
screw the She-Hulk I could hear that uh
Fred
to tessiori
as old Jaws I know that name but I don't
know where from I think they all did a
really good job I'll take your word on
that
Christopher Robin was a decent film he
thinks I I mean it seemed decent but it
just seeing the trailers I'm like this
looks too Melancholy for me right now
favorite Doctor Who audio dramas uh
I mean pretty much any of the ones
written by Robert Sherman
are going to be uh gonna be up towards
the top
uh and also Missy and uh the first
series of Missy in the first series of
the war Master that's not to say
um
that's not to say that uh the series
after the first ones weren't good but I
have not listened to them past that uh I
would like to someday
now that cease to do is over what's your
favorite and least favorite episodes of
vowel house I don't think I
really have a definitive least favorite
my favorite is probably still Grom
um
but I don't think I have a least
favorite hold on
there we go
Fred uh testatory is the voice of Shacks
on Star Trek lower decks I've only ever
seen the first episode of that so that
doesn't help
thank you for trying please try again
I've been watching classic Who and I've
had Jamie shouting uh we happen to be on
the island stuck in my head for weeks
now I like Christopher Robin but it was
depressing I see like for classic who I
love Jamie Jamie and Ace really compete
for my favorite classic companion
they're both so good
Supreme Omega I think very very much for
the Super Chat on X-Men do you agree
with Claremont that Gene's Revival was
still a mistake because Reviving jeans
sort of ruined uh cyclops's development
with Maddie kind of hard to root for a
hero ditches his wife and kid I mean
whether or not you think it's a mistake
I suppose
uh depends somewhat on whether you think
Cyclops is a character worth preserving
the Integrity of
like here's the thing
Cyclops is kind of the worst
he's kind of a selfish [ __ ]
but
um
I don't think that's bad for writing I
think having a guy who's a decent leader
but kind of a bad person
is not a bad or uninteresting way to
handle things
um
because usually what you get there when
you do that is you get like a leader who
is successful but ultimately is like
kind of a bad leader they're abusive to
the people on their team or whatever but
like it it I find Cyclops that is most
interesting when he is a good team
leader but a bad person like uh in his
personal life and
I don't have a problem with that dynamic
uh where are the big finish series I
keep hearing about them go to
bigfinish.com they're audio Adventures
you can get them digitally or you can
order uh physical copies which is a
thing I encourage these days if you can
afford it
I thought Christopher Robin was
confusing aren't Pooh bearing companies
supposed to be a figment of his
imagination I mean it depends on
interpretation
um however you want to handle that
you're on your own does anyone remember
Spectacular Spider-Man The Avengers
Earth Mightiest Heroes series still some
of the best anime stuff from Marvel I
remember that they existed
yep
not sure the war Master is big is Big
finish uh jumping in point though as it
was so Bleak oh like yeah that one's
tough
um
whether or not the bleakness makes it a
bad jumping on point I think has more to
do with your own personal tastes
um I think narratively you know it's no
worse at jumping on point than any other
Doctor Who
Um audio first series is
it is heavy though that that one
especially oh God oh the sky man holy
crap
that story
Yeah question does anyone remember the
third animated uh Spider-Man show with
Neil Patrick Harris's Spider-Man the end
uh with Peter throwing the suit in the
Hudson after being mind control wasn't
that the um
wasn't that the wonky CGI one wasn't
that like on MTV is that that one
uh loose would be a good Doctor Who
companions so would Marcy loose I think
loose would have a similar Dynamic to
bill with just a slightly higher uh
excitement level
sadly I found uh Todd's latest train
records on Motley Crew rather dull I
mean it wasn't his most exciting but I
also don't care about Motley Crue so
it's hard for me to judge uh do you
think rip Hunter is also a good leader
but not a great person or is he a bad
leader too either way I love him it's
it's hard for me to say because I don't
really know I know about repunter I
don't know him outside of the legends of
Tomorrow TV show in which case he was
as good a leader as anyone was going to
be able to lead that particular crew of
absolute
dipsticks
so you know
uh big finish got me hooked on out of
time Parts one two and three I don't not
sure I know that one
uh
uh they now have way too much of my
money big finish is very good at
collecting all of everybody's money uh
I've never had pumpkin spice before what
does it taste like like pumpkin and
spice it's uh
in the name
Captain Omni thank you very much are you
familiar with Dr Omega he was published
in 1906 and had a spaceship and has
campaigns and funny enough looks like
the first doctor
I'm not familiar given what when it came
out I might have to look it up if only
because that should be in public domain
hmm
companion pitch doctor tries to figure
out why a famous singer disappeared and
was never seen again only to find out
them being a companion is why huh
that'd be interesting
yes 3D animated sorry yeah I did see
some of those Logan not a ton uh but I
did see some of those MTV sucks now MTV
MTV has sucked since the early 2000s to
me the Heyday of MTV was the early 90s
when
they when they first started branching
out for music and they were really
experimental and they were willing to do
weird
stuff
you know that you know that gave us
Beavis and Butthead which is what lasted
but you know that's also the time that
gave us a on flux and the ma the Max and
they were willing to go some weird
places but you know that didn't last
over time
uh Captain Omni once again thank you
thank you very much
it really does help I am looking down
the barrel of a tax bill I'm not excited
about uh also Dr omega's spaceship was
able to slide through time and space
basically Dr Omega is a public domain
version of Doctor Who well
well well well
I will
definitely need to look into that out of
time are the 10th doctor post Waters of
Mars meeting the fourth fifth and sixth
interesting so is that part of
um
uh
uh Time Lord Victorious then
um the out of time Trilogy sees 10 team
up with his fourth fifth sixth against
the Dalek Cybermen and Angels okay my
fave is knocking on Woody's door
uh lumity uh it is Owl
uh dream King
good grief
um
and
uh least is either the body body swap or
the shrinking episode due to being the
most generic and gimmicky I mean those
ones are a bit gimmicky I will grant but
I still had fun with them
um
I got I just I just have fun with hoodie
dude
uh
now I know what friendship tastes like
tastes like a bug
have I ever reviewed Brazil from 1985 I
have not ever reviewed it I have seen it
I don't know if I still uh I at one
point I owned like a quite the Criterion
Collection of it which had like the
theatrical cut
the director's cut in like a full
documentary on it
um I don't know if I still have that I
might have given it away because not
because it's bad but because uh it's one
of those things like Am I Ever Gonna
actually watch this again and at the
time the answer was basically no
probably not
um so I don't know if I still have it
but I did
but no I haven't I haven't reviewed it
what do you think the most satisfying
way to resolve Yaz and the doctor's
relationship could be it seems like
they've written themselves into a corner
with that
the problem is I don't know how you do
it satisfactorily
um
with one special left and also have to
tell whatever story
that special is
I don't know I just don't know
I don't know how you do that like if the
plan was to always pull the trigger on
this they really needed to do it earlier
than we've only got one episode left to
deal with this
that that is more of a bummer than
anything for me on that Captain Omni
coming in once again I'm doing my own
take on Dr Omega for a novel oh cool go
for it yeah absolutely
is pumpkin spice a spice for pumpkins or
spice from Pumpkins I'm confused it is a
taste of pumpkin in addition to a taste
of spice so it is pumpkin and Spice
uh who's worse gergy or Bartok Bartok is
amusing he's deeply unnecessary to the
movies but he's amusing enough
um largely for the voice it's kind of
funny
yeah oh I take care of her for you sir I
give her a ha and uh I yeah like that
sir you know it's he's entertaining
enough gergie's annoying
is just freaking irritating
it's like a furry it's like a furry with
Donald Duck's voice and he's awful
uh
I will say after watching Sandman uh I
kind of found the humans to be kind of
annoying uh and Grading and Rose is
acting a little flat you know still love
the show
um Rose Walker and Jed were probably
some of the weaker performances but also
you know
kid actors dealing with some really
complicated material I think they did
about as well as most would have done
Captain Omni coming in once more greatly
appreciated last bit of Dr Omega trivia
his spaceship is basically a classic
old-timey rocket mixed with a submarine
it is not bigger on the inside however
well I mean doctor had to come up with
some original ideas I suppose
am I familiar with Ben 10 I am
I know it's a thing I've never watched
it
[Music]
um
oh it has a Doctor Who parody oh
interesting
uh Yaz is changing feelings about a male
doctor could be an interesting
resolution I would be shocked if Yaz
sticks through after the Regeneration I
just would be I would be shocked if they
set that up
I'm expecting Clean Slate which is how
these things usually go during the
showrunner handovers
what episode of the revive series would
you recommend to someone who's never
seen Doctor Who I'm hoping to show it to
a friend next year so my advice on that
has been the same for a very long time
um show them blank
now here then I'll explain why the
reason I say show them blink is it is a
completely it's not only a completely
self-contained episode it's a
self-explaining episode it explains the
concept of what is involved in the show
within itself so you actually have to do
almost no prep you show them almost
anything else you're gonna have to
explain well you know the doctor travels
in this thing and it's it's bigger on
the inside that it you will have to
explain none of that if you show them
blink they can just watch it and the
other thing is while blink is not
necessarily the most representative in
terms of this is what Doctor Who's
always like it is an episode that I
think you can say if you watch this and
you didn't like it you will probably
never like this show so that's why I say
do blink
I consider it a test bubble episode
I really liked Rory and Amy's Companions
and Clara was a bit meh you know I mean
I had a lot of issues with Clara I've
gone off multiple times I'll I'll leave
it at that
uh
everyone gergy sacrificed himself and
came back if you really think about it
he's the real hero no he's not he would
have been the real hero if he'd stayed
dead I don't think I was ever so mad at
a character coming back to life I was
like why are you why didn't you stay
dead
ah as though somebody asked about mulled
wine uh it is never a bad time to break
out the mulled wine
so you know
uh
blink is the first slash only episode of
Doctor Who I watched hey that works with
a single disc containing all my shows
and movies be an impractical fantasy
disc
Maybe
like flash drive memory stick some some
kind of single-use some kind of single
self-contained media no probably not
that's probably viable at some point
this is my time you will hear me detect
it goes dingling this stuff
uh what kind of spice I don't know
unless I don't work at
um
Starbucks and I don't encourage anyone
to buy from Starbucks either
ask the writers why they brought him
back I don't care why they brought him
back
I really like I don't care enough about
the movie
uh any new vids planned uh in the break
room for fantasy novels uh like you did
structure breakdown for dreams of fire
they were very helpful
um possibly when I get back into writing
on a regular basis I've because I've
still got
I've still got the audiobook to finish
editing so when I get back into actually
writing on a regular basis again maybe
um but yeah no plans for uh author
Diaries anytime soon
uh sad there's still a small number
examples of barrier gaze and Sandman
depending on how you counted in the
diner episode
there are but I I feel like those kinds
of things are less egregious in
something like the diner episode because
that is a situation where like nobody's
getting out alive so it doesn't feel
targeted in a way when a queer character
is singled out or it feels like they're
singled out you can't claim that with
something like that
um
so you know
I I was actually made slightly more
uncomfortable by the reminder that
um Corinthian basically only targets gay
men
I it's not even that I'd forgotten that
I remembered it but it made me
uncomfortable watching it in a way that
it didn't reading it that might just
have been passage of time
uh
remind you of Snowbell from Stuart
Little I never watched those so I that
doesn't have a ton of meaning to me
uh
question which do you prefer the 90s
Spider-Man look from the animated series
or the more slim look recently I
told they're going if you're gonna have
a teenager haven't be slimming gangly if
he's an adult like just give him a
little muscle definition
ah
Discord yes uh
uh thank you for that uh speaking of
Barry are you guys curious what do you
think of the Orville I have not seen
past I think the first four or five
episodes of the first season uh anyway I
gotta hop over the Discord uh check out
questions there I will be back
presently
let me see
uh if the media companies are pushing a
rent Subscription Service what would
what would be an acceptable compromise
an acceptable compromise would be to get
a time machine go back in time and
strengthen the Anti-Trust laws to stop
these corporations from getting so
monstrously huge that they can force
things into whatever damn shape they
want because there's no competition
anymore and they all just buy each other
until there's only about a half dozen
companies that basically own everything
in entertainment
there you go there's your compromise
event time travel and go back and fix it
like
I don't know I'm not I'm not a
legislator while I advocate for True
ownership I'm I'm not you know I'm not a
policy maker I don't know the best way
to move forward I just know what we've
got is messed up
if you could play any game with the
camera issues that make you want to Yak
which one would you want to play first
um
I don't know maybe
um
maybe Shadow of Mordor I might jump onto
or I might go back and finish portal
if I knew it wasn't going to make me
puke
pie or cobbler mood dependent I would
say
slight lean towards cobbler
um let's see I have a question about the
pronoun they oh
I feel honestly confused when it's used
because I always think they are talking
about more than one physical person now
first let me preface I respect the idea
um with the use of they but just wonder
if there could be a less confusing way
of presenting the idea or maybe it's
just me and I should get used to it I'm
curious if this is a general thing uh
that those exposed to someone using that
pronoun is also confused about okay so
it's it's not an uncommon point of
confusion
it is one of those things that's only
kind of as big a problem as you make it
because the thing is if you think about
it you are used to hearing they in
singular context such as context where
maybe you don't know the gender of
somebody like somebody cuts you off in
traffic who do they think they are
because you didn't see if it was a man
or a woman
um but he but also you might not default
to that uh even if
um
you know if it's a possibility I don't
think I don't think uh initial confusion
or difficulty getting used to it makes
you a bad person
I have needed time to get used to it and
I'm still not perfect in terms of always
remembering to go with they them
pronouns as far as your question
um can it be presented in a less
confusing way
um yes the problem is
language is an ever-evolving thing and
it does and it rarely evolves by mandate
it evolves by
um cultural consensus words get used in
enough ways or frequently enough that
they just get adopted into parlance so
like there are a ton
of gender neutral
um singular third person pronouns
there's a bunch of them you'll even find
some if you go to depending on where you
are in online spaces the problem is
there's no way to force those to become
standard use and so
when you're in for non-binary people who
do not want to use she or he or are
comfortable or makes them dysphoric to
do so you know they're they're in a
position where they're either gonna have
to
try and Hammer into people you know uh
pronouns like zizer or something like
that which most people have never even
heard of and would create an even bigger
mess than they because at least they has
precedent yes even precedent as a
singular
um so they referred to a certain degree
it just becomes easier
hopefully it's someday in the future we
kind of have a culturally agreed upon
third person gender neutral singular
pronoun uh we just don't
at present and so they is the best we've
got
and and the thing is I know it's
confusing now you would be surprised at
your ability to get used to it if you
can just kind of get out of your own
head and not think about it so hard it
it goes smoother than you'd think
have you ever played or would you try
Minecraft I have never played Minecraft
the general
um lack of Direction fails to appeal to
me and also uh even though it's super
blocky fully rendered 3D would probably
make me motion sick so no I don't plan
to try it what's the most aesthetically
pleasing or beautiful game you've seen
in your opinion oh
I don't um
Spirit Pharaoh would be up there
um
yeah I think that's probably what I give
it to
at this point do you have any advice for
one newly moved out trans guy
and that's a little vague uh I mean if
you have if you are fairly
um
if you're fairly new to
uh you know being out on your own just
find your people find a community that
makes you comfortable and that may or
may not be a queer focused community
that could be a nerd community that
could be a book club
um it could be whatever but you know go
find your people
that's that's that's my advice
um
given
um that we've got both rings of power
and House of the Dragon right now it
seems the time is right for Reviving but
love fantasy world's full of epic
battles and magic and dragons and stuff
but it seems they've missed an important
one so when do you think they'll bring
back galavant uh
see I know I know they left a dangling
thread that they could have picked up
for a third season but I kind of feel
like galavant has the perfect ending
just Richard's look to the camera I have
a dragon oh it's so good so good I'm
gonna I'm going next to you next year
damn it I am gonna get to a video talk
about how much I love Richard's Arc as a
character in that show God I love it
um it's gonna have to wait because it's
like it's gonna get real low views like
things same way the cool world video did
but I want to do it for me I want to do
it
uh let's see here
so in the latest Babylon 5 podcast you
talked about how you felt B5 might at
this point you're viewing be leaning too
heavy into fantasy as opposed to science
fiction for your preference at least Ari
the series so far
uh how do you see who in terms of these
General polarizations as it certainly is
in a hard sci-fi though it might dip
into it occasionally so like the thing
is I don't have a general hard rule of I
want all sci-fi to be hard sci-fi with
no fantasy element like I I try and
accept things on their own terms where
something can go south for me which
Babylon 5 has not done yet but has the
potential to do is when you establish a
set and a Vibe mostly rooted in harder
sci-fi but then keep drifting
increasingly into fantasy elements
that's where you have you you hooked me
in on something that you are moving away
from and that's where I can get annoyed
um because like I have no problem with
sci-fi fantasy Star Wars is sci-fi
fantasy
um and Doctor Who you know I've I praise
Doctor Who for being actually pretty
loose with a lot of its rules I think it
frees up a lot of its storytelling the
fact that it does that but
um you know when I feel something has
sold me one thing and I've bought that
but then it starts changing it it feels
like
it feels like the waiter changed my
order
from getting it from me and and giving
it to the kitchen
uh
so okay this is a long one with a lot of
Preamble okay let's see what we got
so the protagonist of my novel X is an
amoral reprehensible ideologue he's the
sort of person who'd burn an orphanage
filled with puppies if he felt it was
for the greater good that sort of thing
oh sounds real Pleasant to make sure I
have a com as completed understanding as
possible for my character I try to
imagine them in random situations to see
how they'd react a few days ago I
wondered how X would react if he found
out his child was trans after one of
their friends accidentally gendered them
correctly in front of him I determined
he would be supportive but not after
threatening the friend to be a bit more
careful about who they told in the
future he might be supportive not but
not everyone is and he'd rather his kid
wasn't killed because someone didn't
think about that and couldn't keep their
mouth shut so Preamble over it got me
thinking with trans rights on the knife
edge that they are
are there any moral implications in
making overly villainous characters
supportive of trans rights on one hand
anyone with a shred of decency would see
it as something humanizing or at least
morally neutral on the other hand it'd
be easy for turfs to argue for it as an
evil person supporting evil thing
not caring that their child was about to
become a victim of the alphabet Mafia
and all that nonsense thoughts well the
first thing is if you're
you you
it's rarely healthy or helpful
to think of anything you do in terms of
how will the worst people on the
internet take this because they're going
to take it horribly no matter what you
do this is this is the turfs this is the
alt writers this is the this is the
manosphere this is the in cells they
will find the worst pop possible way to
interpret literally anything you do
uh whether they interpret it in a way
that makes it sound like you agree with
them or they use that as a way to
villainize their targets
trying to basically trying to [ __ ]
proof your story doesn't work so don't
even don't even worry about what they're
gonna think uh is gonna be my first
thing as to your general question
of whether having a demonstrably bad
person be supportive of trans rights is
somehow undermining of the movement my
immediate answer to that is no
no it's not because there's you know
there's the even even a stopped watch is
right twice a day principle
um and like I think a really good
example is in the recent Chucky TV show
in the first season and like this is
Chucky the killer doll and
um at one point he references what is
possibly one of the most malign movies
in the series which is Seed of Chucky so
he's talking to this kid and remember
this is a serial killer doll uh Alive by
dark magic and he says to to this guy
you know I gotta queer kid you have a
kid gender fluid and you're okay with
that and Chucky just leans forward I'm
not a monster Jake and so like you can
just as easily have a be like look even
this [ __ ]
understands that trans people are not a
problem so I no I would not worry about
it unless unless the way that TR that
trans well so like it seemed like the
scenario you'd asked
was sort of like a hypothetical as a
character exercise so but for the moment
let's assume it actually becomes part of
the narrative
um if that is to happen in your story as
long as it doesn't seem like an awful
decision that he makes pivots on his
support of trans rights if that's just
also a thing he believes in
I do I personally and I can't speak for
the entire queer Community it's not a
monolith but I personally would not see
a problem with that
so there we go
uh
let's see I think I think that's
everything question uh jump gate how
many drinking games do you want to start
with chess with Jesse saying Sinclair
versus Sheridan unfortunately she's
gotten better as it's gone along that
first one though that first one I should
have made her take a shot every time she
got it wrong that oh that would have
been so good
Mike I might try and figure out I kind
of want to go back and do a count if
nothing else anyways that uh should wrap
up the Discord
um because we have a Time cut off
um all questions have to be in before
the
stream starts so coming back here we are
I'm back now
ah so we've got
new Super Chat thank you Supreme Omega
very very a very much in an interview uh
didio felt Wally was never his own
character and was way too subservient to
bury uh and his uh presence complicates
The Flash franchise way too much
hmm
um
given that I bowed out of The Flash TV
show before Wally was introduced I can't
really give my own opinion
of that
um as an assessment what I can say is I
never got the impression that the CW
shows did a more traditional hero
sidekick Dynamic and if you're not going
to do that yes I I can see where that
those concerns of those arguments would
come from again I can't verify that
because I bailed after season
after the end of season two I think
I think that was I think that was as far
as I got
uh could the Klingon High Chancellor
work as a puppet
sure why not
[Laughter]
who do you think has the best character
Arc in all of Television that you've
seen I I don't have a have a short
answer for that
um I can I can give you like the short
list of considerations off the top of my
head Wesley Windham price King Richard
um
Catra
uh would be on there as well
um
trying to think
those those are those would be the big
three off the top of my head uh there's
probably some others if I actually like
sat down and thought about it for longer
any good comebacks to get will go broke
tired of hearing it looking for the best
thing to say uh yeah block whoever said
it so you don't have to listen to them
again honestly like I I know it would
feel good to have a good comeback but
like they're never gonna listen and
they're just gonna keep being jerks and
you're better off
ignoring them I I know sometimes don't
feed the trolls is really unsatisfying
as a piece of advice but like some
sometimes it's just true I don't
remember but have you ever engaged with
Rick Rick and Morty in any way it's a
guilty pleasure for me uh when I just
want to feel awful I watched the first
I think three episodes of Rick and Morty
at which point I bailed because I just I
I hate
I hate the characters
I don't like any of them I don't like
spending time with them I don't like
listening to them I don't like I don't
like the voices I don't like the
characterization I don't like these
people like at all and I also kind of
hate how much of the dialogue is
improvised because like
it's one of the things when somebody
tries to tell me is like a trivia thing
um hey you know most of these most of
the dialogue is improvised my answer is
yeah I can freaking tell
cause it's not good
um yeah I just
I can see why it's clever I don't think
it's this dumb show I can see where it's
intelligent I can see where it's well
thought out I can see where it's
creative but God do I not want to spend
time with those people like at all
any of them You Gotta Give me one
character I can latch on to but like no
I did not like any of them at
all at all
uh seeing as his performance Gilmore
made me realize how truly wasted Stephen
Fry was in his Doctor Who appearance I
mean I'm assuming they only had him to
shoot for a day
that's kind of my assumption on that
uh
do you have a favorite episode of The
Prisoner
um it's been too long since I've watched
it
I kind of feel like the first episode is
kind of perfect but like it's been it's
been way too long since I've watched The
Prisoner
ah I wish the Remake had not been crap
had such a good cast
something I do like about the Guardians
of the Galaxy game is that it's 10 movie
influence 90 comic influence and it's a
mat and as a massive comic fan it's
really cool that they mentioned darkhawk
oh God dark Hawk
I have I have multiple issues of dark
Hawk from the 90s oh that guy
oh
I forget about him and then it's like
right
big thing Ari avatar The Last Airbender
is that when you contrast uh him to
Bellows or the core or the uh brother's
horde of the true antagonists of
infinity train firelord ozai is
extremely simplistic
I mean I I didn't get as I didn't get
far enough in avatar The Last Airbender
to actually meet him as a character he
just talked about
uh
let's see where was I hey do you
remember me from your back from the
beach live stream I was the one who said
I love your videos I think I do Riley
I'm like I'm not always great like
asking me do I remember you from the
last live stream is not
like it's not the best
uh best dude like ADHD it's it's a thing
I'm gonna try and wrap it up soon any
tips on starting a podcast I'm starting
one pretty soon I have planned for a few
months uh yeah record a bunch of
episodes before you launch the first one
so that if you ever need to take a week
off you've you've got a cushion
build yourself up a cushion before you
before you put your first episode live
that's my advice
uh what cartoon am I gonna review next I
recommend either paranormal Part 12
forever or be in the puppy cat I don't
know at present uh what my kiddo and I
are currently watching is we are
catching up on uh the remainder of
season one of ghost and Molly McGee I
might give my thoughts on that I don't
know how much I'm gonna have to say
I don't know we'll see
uh trying to catch up so we can wrap it
out
since I can't watch the remastered
version of Babylon 5 I have Canadian
Amazon not American any other sci-fi
shows to recommend I mean Farscape
always plug Farscape
um
excited hoping for a second season of
Peacemaker I'm I mean like it's pretty
much confirmed they're doing a second
season so far as I'm aware uh that was
yeah that was a real good that was a
real good show how far did I get into
Avatar I watched the first two seasons
only did a review for the first one
and again like as I've said every single
time it has come up for me I don't think
it's bad but I've seen too many things
that took the template of what it did
and did more with it that if I'd watch
it at the time it aired I think I would
have a similar level of appreciation to
you know so many people but I didn't
and it can't impact me watching it now
the way it did when or even within the
first five eight years of when it aired
so
I yeah I don't know what to say at this
point
Captain Omni thank you very much uh as
someone who has read Savage dragon for
years
I can say uh that's like watching a
really cool race car going fast before
heading into a horrific crash I I have a
couple of uh collected volumes of Savage
dragon
it's not good but it's kind of great
if you've read it that might make sense
have you seen any of the Doctor Who
animations of the missing episodes if so
what's your favorite I've seen a few
um I've seen the half animated
Recreation of Shada I've seen
crap something of the dialects power of
the Daleks I think it is the the first
trouton one
um I think that's all I've seen for the
animated Recreations I haven't seen that
many of them yet
I thought you lost interest in Ghost and
Molly McGee well no it wasn't that we
lost interest is that we watched the
first five episodes when those hit
um Disney plus and then we moved on to
other stuff you know and there weren't
new episodes on and then we just kept
doing other stuff but now that we've
wrapped up the other stuff we were
watching you know we're circling back on
it
my takeaway of the Corinthian is he's
supposed to be a representation for the
dark sides of people so the fact that he
targets gay people while I was a little
turned off it makes sense like I get it
it just still made me feel a little bit
on the subject of Babylon 5 Claudia
Christian was in big Finnish audios
Perry's mom
who is she on Beyond Babylon five I'm
not good with actor names I'm I'm
super not
uh favorite guilty pleasure
I don't know I'll throw out a Rand a
random one out there uh Liz and I
rewatched gunpowder milkshake over the
weekend that movie's real good it's real
dumb but it's real good
uh
uh re the ghost of Molly McGee and the
character of Libby hirchian Molly are
adorable together
um yeah yeah they are
oh that's Ivanova thank you Rowan thank
you for clarifying that guilty pleasure
sci-fi movie
um
I don't know
space truckers I don't know
anyways uh I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna wrap
it up there
um thank you everybody for for tuning in
thank you for the super chats thank you
for spending time and listening to me
thank you for the well wishes regarding
the passing of one of the family rats
thank you
for all of it
I hope that you have a great
um rest of your week
uh tomorrow I will be streaming on
Twitch I'll be playing more Loop hero
um because I'm still into that so I'll
be playing more of that and uh
uh within the next hopefully half hour
or so my review of the third episode of
House of the Dragon will be up in the
break room of Geeks
um on Thursday I'll have a review out
for the next episode of
uh She-Hulk attorney at law and then
Friday is more twitch
um probably still Loop hero and then
Saturday is going to be a video giving
the uh as as marking
the excuse me the 10th anniversary of
the channel it is a complete ish history
of Council of Geeks so you have that to
look forward to all this stuff going on
during the week and
um I hope to to see you all there but uh
really what I want you to remember is
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
my cavity